and you're building yourself a media
Empire
um congratulations on the new show thank
you uh I think it's dope too because I
saw like kind of like the well first of
all I I always preferred Hollywood
unlocked over shade room and baller
alert because I always thought you guys
when we would do stuff just be
controversial out the gate no no I'm
being honest damn if I should what's up
Angie and Robin no no they're great I'm
letting you know if I if you were to go
to my saved posts yeah over the last
like six years ninety percent of all of
my news
it's Hollywood it's Hollywood unlocked
bro why why Hollywood unlocked I just
feel like you guys were like like I feel
like you guys are more like
uh active I guess if that makes sense I
feel like baller alerts sometimes like I
might get like five or six posts a day
some days where like if I'm like really
trying to see what the [__] like going
on like in real time like I'll go to you
or you know even like my mixtapes like
post [__] like I like but they're pretty
active too they're like super active but
I do feel like you know you've kind of
all uh for me been like a great source
of like doing show prep you know just as
a radio personality and now you're
[__] killing it I've you know I loved
what you were doing with damage
um during the pandemic
um and to see you kind of
turn into
Jason Lee being kind of like as big or
bigger than your company and the Jason
Lee show man just congrats thank you
thank you yeah I first want to shout out
Robin and and um and Angie two amazing
women who you know inspire me in
different ways Angie at the showroom was
somebody who was shade rooms like the
like the the Michael Jordan of this
right there well we're all different you
know that's the thing you know when I
first came in the game everybody was
saying oh don't do Hollywood a lot
because the shade room and ball alert's
been here before everybody and shape
room has as many followers and there's
no room in the space and I always
believed in myself I was always like
[__] what y'all talking about I'm gonna
do what I want to do I mean I'm a person
who survived the hood I came out of
nothing I [__] been shot I've seen
all types of [__] happen like there's no
way you survive all that and think that
you can't be anything you want to be
Angie at the showroom was the first to
really like guide me on how to build
she's super cool too she's a sweetheart
yeah how to build audience how to really
connect with them and how to focus on
your content and then Robin when I lost
my Instagram was the person who guided
me through the lawsuit and checked on me
every day and until today with the new
show checks on me and we have a great
relationship and they have a dope baller
alert radio is dope they're both dope
all alerts in the films we're all just
very different I think the one thing
that makes us unique where I think you
see me more is Jason Lee is also a brand
in the face of Hollywood online so you
see me a lot more you hear my shows and
my interviews and so you see me more I
don't know that's what whoever's posting
for y'all is just on top of it bro
they're on it they're killing it like
I'm like it's crazy because like I used
to be like let me check tfz or something
like no let me see Hollywood a lot
posted I know yo I know when you posted
that the queen died me and my co-host
James Jefferson we were like praying we
were like and and this is like a bad
thing okay we weren't we weren't praying
that she was no y'all wanted her to be
dead no we didn't want her to be dead
you wanted the story but I was like very
like I was like oh this is huge yeah
this would be huge if Jason Nails it hot
like when something like that happens
obviously it didn't end she ended up
passing away after but allegedly oh
listen social media you know they killed
me oh I was wrong and then you know you
didn't really see her and then they came
back and said oh Jason was right the
whole time you know you know I have to
say in the business that I'm in you have
to trust your sources
I've learned a lot since that experience
though like you try I still trust the
source because the source if I ever said
the source which I won't I mean is
somebody that all of us would just gag
if you just heard the person who told me
but then shout out to Prince Harry I'm
kidding okay no it wasn't her I wish but
no I mean like but then at this on the
other hand it was a huge Gamble and you
know we rode the dice and you know
sometimes you hit and sometimes you
don't and it was just one of those
things where I loved that I went through
that because it just showed everybody
that I was human we made a mistake you
know we came back and owned it and we
corrected and we kept it pushing and we
we're still getting deals we're still
growing you know so